on live bienvenue bonjour à tous je suis
aujourd'hui avec guillaume et cédric du
service des sports du figaro et vous
parler aujourd'hui du lancement de la
ligue 1 le championnat qui commence
demain avec un alléchant as monaco
olympique lyonnais
on va faire un peu le tour sur les
favoris enfin le fawe le grand favori le
podium les relégables à quoi s'attendre
un peu de pronostics on va se mouiller
bien sûr on n'oublie pas que le mercato
n'est pas terminé donc j'ai encore
beaucoup de choses qui peuvent changer
mais ça on en parlera au fur et à mesure
vous n'oubliez pas tout au long de ce
live à nous poser des questions
et c'est là que seront ravis d'y
répondre plaisir et on va commencer à
part une pas la première des questions
c est ce que le psg sera champion cette
année
non non c'est évidemment évidemment tout
le monde pense que le psg va être va
être champion cette année c'est logique
à la fois le budget la force de frappe
budgétaire et aussi sur le terrain de
des parisiens
finalement l'effectif n'a pas tellement
bougé alors évidemment il ya
l'interrogation neymar ce qui peut
changer beaucoup de choses sur le sur la
saison parisienne
ils ont fait un mercato plutôt
intelligent moins clinquant peut-être
que les saisons précédentes ils ont
amélioré quelques points notamment le
milieu terrain où il y avait vraiment un
manque de ce côté là on l'a vu la saison
dernière avec les arrivées de dents des
rae rae de pablo sarabia de joueurs qui
se sont bien intégrés tout de suite on
l'a vu ils ont fait une bonne pré saison
malheureusement en derrière assez blessé
donc il va rater le début de la ligue 1
mais voilà deux bonnes de bonnes pioches
à priori pour le psg plus guèye qui
arrive d'everton donc cette sentinelle
que vous voulez absolument thomas
schoorel donc c'est plutôt de bonne
augure pour le psg sauf qu'il ya
toujours cette interrogation démarre
donc voilà on va attendre
leonardo a dit qu'ils voudraient être
fixés avant le début de la saison
d'higuain là ça risque d'être compliqué
quand même puisque on est à deux trois
jours du premier match du psg mais la
saison 2 ne devrait pas échapper au psg
en tout cas en lien et s'assurer que
vous est-ce que tu partages ce constat
oui c'est difficile d'en faire un autre
après il faut maintenant falloir voir
effectivement comment ils vont gérer le
cas neymar parce que c'est un vrai c'est
un vrai souci s'il reste dans quel état
d'esprit est là comment il va être
accueilli par le public parisien
s'il part comment ils font plus pour le
remplacer puisque à priori le mercato en
grande bretagne en premier league
s'arrête aujourd'hui donc ça va être
difficile ensuite d'aller chercher un
joueur de d'envergure internationale en
angleterre mais quand le seul autorisé
en angleterre sur sky mais a priori les
clubs anglais oui c'est pas on s'en
doute pas d'un d'un top players donc
size of horror mais bon en lien il n'y
aura pas de suspense
le suspens est de savoir ce qu'ils
peuvent être champion dès début avril
on se souvient l'année dernière à mi
saison il avait 19 points d'avance déjà
après seulement 19 journées ils ont fini
avec 16 points d'avancé 3 sur l'île
voilà donc c'était un c'était une balade
du psg la saison dernière
malheureusement je pense
qu'effectivement je pense qu'il faut
qu'on s'attende à ce genre de ce genre
de schéma encore cette année même si
beaucoup de gens pensent que lyon est
capable de titiller le psg mais je pense
qu'on va en parler après on va en parler
un peu plus tard pour en revenir un peu
sur le paris saint germain est ce qu'ils
ont réservé des gros problèmes qui était
le milieu de terrain qui était assez
assez faible jusque là ils ont quand
même recruter ra sarah bien on l'a dit
guay est ce que le psg cette année plus
forts que ceux de l'an dernier
plus fort ce jeu c'est pas aussi
difficile à dire au milieu de terrain
peut-être et encore moi je suis pas je
suis pas un grand fan des rires ah je
pense que si il jouait quand même pas
énormément à manchester united il s'est
pas vraiment imposé
voilà galaye galice et sur doute un bon
joueur mais bon c'est pas un jeune
joueur c'est pas non plus un top un top
milieu de terrain on sera bien c'est un
profil un peu différent beaucoup plus
offensif ils ont résolu un petit quelque
chose mais c'est pas voilà c'est pas
sais pas encore ce que j'espérais je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas encore pris le
joueur la sentinelle de calibre
international où on se dit que là ça va
vraiment passé à autre chose
donc est-ce que c'est plus fort mais on
en revient à toujours la question des
marci neymar s'en va comment le
remplacer tout pour l'instant il ya
c'est pas évident que ce soit plus fort
ce sera compliqué effectivement alors on
a une première réaction d'alain
internautes qui nous dit que lui il voit
un podium avec psg lyon et bordeaux est
ce que vous voyez bordeaux sur le podium
c'est une très grosse cote bande ou sur
les podiums on a eu le président de joda
groza dans nos colonnes il ya deux jours
qui nous disait qu y viser la première
partie de tableau qui était un peu plus
un peu plus modestes on va dire ça me
paraît compliqué dès cette saison le
podium pour pour les girondins vu le
l'effectif actuel ils ont fait un très
gros coup avec laurent koscielny
clairement ça qu'ils ont recruté un bon
joueur un joueur de cassis des joueurs
du calibre international à capitaine
d'arsenal pendant neuf ans pour la ligue
clairement la faire un bon un très bon
joueur pré retraite
oui aux trente trois ans il peut encore
il encore quelques de tiassalé été
souvent blessé
allez pour la ligue 1 on va dire que ça
va passer mais on grince aussi je suis
désolé pour pour l'internaute là mais
pour moi bordeaux sera sans doute la
déception de l'année alors on va avant
de parler un peu plus tard des
déceptions on reste un peu sur paris
avant de parler de notre podium vous
n'hésitez pas à nous dire dans les
commentaires
quel est selon vous le podium de la
ligue 1 quel sera le podium de la ligue
1 on lui demande est ce que le psg a
intérêt à revendre neymar est est ce que
les pommes et qu'un prêt avec les
préparateurs physiques de du psg je
pense pas qu'ils aient problème
particulier avec les préparateurs
physiques du psg c'est malheureusement
le lot de tous les clubs d'avoir d'avoir
des blessés concernant neymar c'est
toujours pareil ce qu'on retient un
joueur contre sa volonté
pour l'instant le psg joue la montre ce
qui de toute façon ils ont pas d'offre
ils veulent leur 300 millions ou un
petit peu moins en tout cas ils ont pas
d'offres concrètes que ce soit de la
part du barça de barcelone dont on parle
depuis des semaines mais finalement ils
n'ont jamais encore fait d'offre
concrète
et puis on parle aussi du real madrid
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils sont prêts à
mettre un gros billet sur neymar pas
suivre alors ce qu'il faut le revendre
enfin moi j'ai envie de dire non c'est
quand même le troisième on considère
comme le troisième meilleur joueur
derrière cristiano ronaldo et messi dans
le monde
ce serait vraiment terrible de se dire
qu'il faut séparer de neymar à tout prix
après de l'autre côté ça que s'il n'est
pas concilier pas heureux à paris
puisque apparemment c'est le cas que ce
soit dans sa vie privée et même au psg
difficile difficile de garder un joueur
contre son gré en sachant qui peut poser
problème après durant la saison
ce qu'il faudrait c'est qu'ils arrivent
à le re mobiliser à lui dire que voilà
il faut qu'il faut qu'il se tienne dans
l'équipe et que voilà qui repartent sur
une saison pour pour toujours essayer de
conquérir des titres et notamment sa
quête du ballon d'or parce que c'est il
est venu associe à paris pour ça donc
s'ils arrivent à le re mobiliser
évidemment qu'il faut pas il faut pas
séparer de l'ema mais est ce que il ya
encore rattrapable ça je sais pas on a
l'impression qu'il a déjà l'esprit un
petit peu ailleurs neymar cédric moi je
pense qu'il faut le vendre
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y là haut
niveau de l'état d'esprit il n'y est pas
il croit il a pas l'air de croire encore
au projet parisien
je pense que interview qui avait donné
un cadet fille était très clair sur le
sujet le problème des préparateurs
physiques au psg à mon avis il y en a
pas je pense qu'il ya un problème de
boîte de nuit
on parie à paris vis-à-vis de neymar je
précise guillaume unis qui déposeront
dans sa vie privée ce jeu c'est poche
pour ce qu'il a l'air de bien se sentir
qu'il a l'air de se faire plaisir
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'il ait une
hygiène de vie
qu'ils soient à la hauteur de son talent
voilà après le remobiliser je n'arrive
pas à voir les leviers aujourd'hui que
pourraient utiliser les dirigeants du
psg tourelles je joue à pas exactement
moi je pense qu'il faut il faut sont
séparés le problème c'est qu'il aurait
fallu déjà censé pas il ya eu une ou
deux semaines pour pour vraiment bien
préparé la saison aussi si vous en
séparer le 28 août et que vous vous
retrouvez en commun comme des anglais en
panique bail c'est à dire ensuite
essayer de prendre un mec pour le
remplacer et hou là là par contre il
vaut peut-être mieux gardé même s'il
n'est pas très motivé la thématique ces
personnes ne peut mettre l'argent que le
psg souhaite donc ils peuvent se
retrouver au 31 août au 2 septembre la
fin du mercato avec neymar dans
l'effectif
qu'est ce qu'ils font et que fait neymar
ce qu'il est prêt à mettre une saison
entière entre parenthèse dans sa
carrière il a déjà 27 ans le temps
commence à filer aussi ils auraient tout
intérêt
effectivement faire son mea le coup son
mea culpa on a déjà vu des joueurs par
le passé faire volte-face genre qu'il
voulait absolument partir
puis finalement se dire que bon il était
pas au bagne le psg c'est quand même un
grand club il ya combien plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros par an
voilà mais après est-ce que c'est vrai
que cédric a raison et ce qu'ils disent
que finalement il est capable de se
mobiliser avec le psg c'est
l'interrogation est ce qu'on peut
imaginer une situation à peu à la radio
avec neymar dans des mares jour il
jouera deux aucun souci à ce niveau là
en plus c'est pas le même statut c'est
pas là
non c'est impossible pour une même
situation maintenant ça peut être ça
peut être vraiment je vais peut-être
employés un mois un peu fort un peu il
peut être toxique pour un vestiaire nema
donc à bon il ay là et il a perdu dani
alves et tous qui était qui a été un peu
son lieutenant ou quelque chose comme ça
donc mais mais en plus on voit on
commence à voir des petites images des
choses salaire ça pue l'air d'être le
grand amour avec avec kilian mba paie
donc
en tout cas ils ont bien caché en chine
parce que sur les entraînements etc
on a vu quand même une certaine
complicité entre les deux donc s'il joue
un rôle il le joue très bien et mars
qu'on a quand même vu qu'ils étaient
assez proches des joueurs très souriant
que ce soit avec di maria marquinhos
lors des entraînements on l'a vu aussi
en coulisses à shenzhen
après le trophée des champions il
plaisantait avec avec kevin trappe il
avait l'air plutôt plutôt content mais
après ce que ces voix là est ce que
c'est une façade
probablement puisque on a vu aussi que
les tensions étaient toujours assez vive
avec les dirigeants dont peut-être
qu'ils sont encore bien que ses
coéquipiers mais que la cassure est déjà
fait avec ses dirigeants et du coup
c'est plus réparable
difficile à dire d'accord on verra du
coup à la fin de cette saison on voit
déjà la fin du mercato où sera neymar
mais en tout cas pour vous effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit le l'archi favori
s'est une nouvelle fois le paris
saint-germain maintenant on va peut
rebondir ce que disait non plus notre
internet sur le podium de la ligue 1 le
podium possible qui vous voyez
accompagné pendant paris sur ce podium
je pense qu'on est d'accord sur lyon oui
on l'a mis à la deuxième position c'est
vrai que c'est c'est l'équipe qui paraît
la mieux armée pour pour terminer
deuxième raison et être ils ont été
devancés par par line l'année dernière
qui était vraiment une grosse surprise
mais voilà on pense que lyon a toutes
les armes pour finir deuxième que ce
soit en termes d'effectifs
il ya aussi un vrai renouveau avec
sylvinho et juninho en tant que
directeur sportif
il ya quand même une interrogation on
sait pas s'il faut que la mayonnaise
prenne vite puisque cédric le disais il
jouer contre monaco dès vendredi voilà
on sait jamais il peut y avoir un
accident d'entrée du coup derrière on
court un petit peu après le temps la
mode qu'il a la confiance a du mal à
venir et ça peut ça peut engendrer des
problèmes assez rapidement mais voilà
sur le papier en tout cas le projet il
est très séduisant
on a vu un sylvinho qui a décalé
principe qu'il y ait des convictions en
terme de jeu je pense qu'il faut
proposer quelque chose d'assez ambitieux
avec ce 4 3 3 même s'il a fait d'autres
tests pendant les pendant la préparation
après en terme d'effectif je vais passer
la main à cédric est ce que c'est ce que
lyon est meilleur que l'année dernière
je suis pas tout à fait sûr non pas
meilleur il risque d'être différent la
question situe au milieu de terrain je
pense que l'est mais notamment dans le
dans l'impact c'est vrai que non mais là
était un joueur extraordinaire qu'ils
étaient capables de casser les lignes
qui a été capable d'apporter quelque
chose sur le plan offensif
aujourd'hui lyon n'a plus d'appuis ce
profil-là tiago mendes et est un super
joueur
on l'a vu à lille mais ça rien à voir
avec un de nos aînés ils ont perdu fekir
qui étonne aussi un détonateur même si
la saison dernière à une saison en dents
de scie les blessures et les choses
comme ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
grande question à lyon savait qu à voir
c'est à dire est ce qu'on va retrouver
le avoir déjà deux ans qui était
vraiment kim à réduire leurs oeufs qui
marchait sur l'eau ou alors l'award
l'année dernière qui a fait quelques
bons matchs qui étaient moins bons sur
d'autres s'il retrouve son niveau il ya
deux ans ça va compenser le départ des
nommés les tiago mendes à ses côtés
c'est du solide c'est intéressant
et puis il faut aussi voir de paille
parce que de paille de paille pour
l'instant il parle beaucoup il a montré
certaines choses ou à un moment mais bon
c'est pareil c'est en dents de scie et
c'est pour ça que l'on a fini six mois
l'année dernière de paris c'est à dire
que on a vu contre le psg et qu'ils
étaient capables de les battre qu'ils
étaient capables de les accrocher
et puis mes deux de se rater sur sur des
matches
je sais plus à dijon par des adversaires
qu'ils ont battus mais donc pour moi
pour l'instant l'effectif est moins fort
mais mais c'est quand même cohérent et
franchement ça vaut une deuxième place
une deuxième place donc de paille vous
l'avez dit une saison très irrégulière
et à l'avant un moussa dembélé qui a peu
porté l'équipe en fin de saison dernière
on parle de lui pour partir jean michel
aulas est dit normalement il ne devrait
pas bouger et on l'espère pour lyon
puisque s'il part ce serait un peu le
pas le désert derrière lui mais sauf
erreur il faut surtout pas qu'ils
partent et il partira pas effectivement
je pense que ce sera la saison ce sera
vraiment la saison de la confirmation
pour lui en ligue 1 il a tous les atouts
pour pour cartonner
je sais pas s'il ira titiller quillanais
mbappé dont classement des buteurs mais
ce sera difficile mais oui ce sera
vraiment à un atout majeur pour lui ou
encore cette saison
il ya une petite interrogation ces
fameux défend en défense et que former
andersen qui a été recruté quand même
presque 30 min 30 millions d'euros ce
qui représente le plus gros transfert
d'histoire de lyon alors que vaut ce
jeune danois suédois danois danois ya
une interrogation il vient de la
sampdoria de gênes il n'y a pas de gros
clubs italiens qui sont positionnées sur
lui ce qui est assez étrange
donc voilà on attend de voir on nous
présente un peu comme de l'irt bis
j'espère que j'espère que ça va aller
voir un peu à faire ailleurs quand même
si dans tous les gros ça serait bien
c'est ça c'est ça c'est un peu
l'interrogation effectivement ils ont
dit quand même un gros billet sur sur ce
jour là donc on attend
après marcelo qui est qu'il est censé
remplacer connu une saison très
difficile l'année dernière je compte au
final ils prennent pas un très gros
risque avec avec ce jour là il ya aussi
une interrogation sur notre ami lopes
anthony lopes donc un super gardien
probablement pour ma part en tout cas je
pense que c'est le meilleur gardien de
ligue 1 actuellement qui n'a pas encore
prolongé son contrat qu un petit peu en
froid avec ses dirigeants
voilà les supporters lyonnais espère que
ça va que ça va vite se décanter de ce
côté là parce qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir
un gardien en confiance avec une fois de
plus en plus une doublure qui a été qui
a été recruté oui c'est plate à rossano
qui jouait avant à nantes et qui a fait
quelques quelques sorties on va dire un
peu osée en disant je suis pas ici pour
l'être pour être numéro 2 mais oui
c'était un petit peu ça a jeté un petit
peu un froid lors de sa conférence de
presse parce que sa queue
il a clairement fait comprendre qu'ils
venaient pour pour le poste de numéro un
bouc parler des petites attentions mais
en plus anthony lopes peut-être pas
forcément vu d'un point de vue extérieur
le gars sont plus faciles à vivre donc
on va c'est un compétiteur
samedi temps on se rappelle de ses coups
de sang même s'il a fait beaucoup
d'efforts par rapport à ça on le sait
après ils sont bien encadrés avec
grégory coupet qui l'ont évidemment le
l'entraîneur qu'il faut pour pour régler
tous les problèmes s'il ya des problèmes
le cadre est effectivement comme on l'a
dit pour accompagner lyon sur ce podium
vous voyez une équipe différente l'un et
l'autre qui sait que vous et moi je vois
marseille
je fais un petit pari sur marseille un
gros pari ouais ça fait six ans qu'ils
ont pas qu'ils ont pas joué là qu'ils
ont qui sont pas qualifiés pour la ligue
des champions marseille voilà le vent du
renouveau sur sur la canebière me séduit
ou avec andré villas-boas je pense
qu'ils ont ils ont un entraîneur
vraiment de très gros calibre qui a déjà
fait ses preuves à l'étranger alors ça
c'est pas toujours très bien passé
notamment tottenham mais voilà je crois
vraiment à ce projet il a il a des
convictions en terme de jeu il est une
grosse personnalité il est un charmeur
il a déjà fait l'unanimité au club dans
le vestiaire aussi on voit que ça marche
auprès des cadres un mandanda qui est
revenue très affûté après une saison
compliquée on a vu aussi un dimitri
payet qui a fait une bonne préparation
après une chute et tout comme mandanda
futé aussi voilà il et on sent décisif
on sent prêt à repartir au combat on
sait qu'il ya un euro qui arrive
derrière que les années de grande
compétition générale dimitri payet il se
réveille un petit peu il se montre on va
peut-être ces deux de redistribuer les
cartes dans l'équipe de didier deschamps
et puis et puis le recrutement alors
effectivement pour l'instant c'est pas
terrible entre car ils disent attendre
plus de joueurs il ya et dario benedetto
ils ont quand même recruter ce numéro 9
le fameux grand attaquant qu'ils
attendaient alors est-ce qu'il est assez
grand pour l'om
on va le savoir le savoir bientôt il a
quand même mis beaucoup de buts avec
boca juniors une 46 buts trois en 76
matchs quelque chose comme ça le souci
c'est qu'il s'est gravement blessé il ya
un peu moins de deux ans il a une
rupture des ligaments du genou je crois
et du coup il a eu un petit peu de mal à
revenir derrière il ya beaucoup de
pression à marseille on sait bien que
les supporters attendent vraiment qu'il
ya un grand attaquant on a vu balotelli
a fait a fait le taf pendant six mois
mais ils ont grand besoin de quelqu'un
qui s'inscrivent dans la durée avec la
ferveur du vélodrome un argentin avec ça
sa grinta moi j'ai l'impression que
paris va va être réussi en tout cas je
fais le pari que ça va marcher
on verra cédric tu as tu as l'air d'y
croire un petit peu moins à tout ça
alors j'y crois pas du tout mais bon sur
l'entraîneur je suis je suis totalement
d'accord
guillaume avril à ce beau gosse a le
charisme le tinland les compétences pour
essayer de faire quelque chose de bien
savoir motiver certains joueurs ça c'est
certain
après le vent du renouveau en fait on
parle que d'eux
que d'anciens joueurs on parle de
mandanda on parle de paillettes parce
qu'il ya pas de recrutement parce que
benedetto là pour moi ça me parle pas je
pense qu'il y avait sans doute moyen de
récupérer les joueurs peut-être un peu
plus intéressant peut-être je sais pas
il ya joie il ya des genevois des noms
comme des échos ben yedder des choses
comme ça ça ça aurait eu plus de plus de
2 des séductions pour moi pourquoi je
crois pas du tout à marseille par contre
je crois un autre club qui s'est bien
rater la saison dernière c'est monaco
là je pense que il ya moyen de faire
quelque chose on va ils vont éviter le
psychodrame de prendre des entraîneurs
pour les virer pour les reprendre pour
les orphelins à faire n'importe quoi en
terme de recrutement là j'ai trouvé que
c'était quand même plus structuré plus
en plus intelligents
difficile de faire pire oui c'est
certain alors d'un impôt l'impression
que c'est vrai mais marseille sur le
papier ils ont une belle équipe l'année
dernière il ya eu un accident mais
finalement dans quel secteur il avait
besoin de recruter c'était vraiment en
attaque c'est par benedetto qui va
changer grand chose à mon avis et puis
et puis donc je veux citer des noms de
data comme ben yedder peut-être que
falcao peut-être partir de monaco peut
être que c'est ben yedder qui vont lui
succéder
on parle ici de mitchie batterie
l'entraînement arriver ça m'intéresse
moi mais mes
un belvédère je trouve que c'est un très
bon attaquant très sous côtés quand on
voit le nombre de but kim fc séville et
tout je trouve que c'est assez assez
parlant donc moi j'attends déjà de voir
la fin du mercato et des joueurs qui
m'intéresse beaucoup à monaco je suis
pressé de voir jouer donc moi je
mettrais plutôt de pièces monaco se
trouve avec james martinez qui a été
gardée martin et martine c'est martin
johnson martins qui a été gardée par par
l'as monaco s'est fait comme une belle
c'est comme une belle prise vous avez
fait un très bon très bon mercato
d'hiver des gens quand on fabrique à ce
jeune sun martins en fait il avait déjà
posé les pierres de cette saison moi
j'ai un bémol s'il y perdre radamel
falcao je pense que ce sera pas la même
saison que c'est le capitaine c'est
l'âme de cette équipe en lamelles falcao
il l'a dit encore hier les aux journaux
de leonardo jardim il veut pas que
falcao parts
j'ai vraiment un point d'interrogation
sur sur l'île c'est à m
avec falcao et sans falcao même si ce
n'est plus le grand le grand buteur
qu'il a pu l'être par le passé
effectivement et puis il ya l'aspect
défensif aussi pour monaco peut être en
parler un peu subasic qui a fait une
saison très moyenne l'an dernier pour le
voile a pas de problème ils ont remplacé
par benjamin lecomte qui a fait qu'ils
étaient donc très bientôt un tribut sur
est-ce que du coup ça aussi c'est un
très bon coup et on récupère également
aguilar qu'elle quitte à montpellier à
ce jour toutes deux situées qu'ils
allaient le pensum sidibé qui est parti
à qui appartient la bertone qui est
d'ailleurs si si et voilà c'est fait
c'est officiel pour poursuivre et ont
ils vont attaquer la saison mieux que le
classement derrière en tout cas web à
l'attaqué mais a priori l'entraîneur
qu'ils ont toute la saison je pense je
leur souhaite
et ouais non sens on sent que c'est
cohérent aguilar c'est bien le compte
c'est que c'est très très bien aussi
blick la saison dernière était en
difficulté mais mais on sait que ça peut
être un très bon défenseur ça peut être
un taulier tout donc ils peuvent s'y
retrouve son niveau
ça va être sinon il n'y a pas de joie
pas de gros points faibles ils ont même
déjà prévu la vente de ronnie lopes a
priori en trouvant son remplaçant donc
qui est un international ly gérer les
géants miniers kourou voilà donc tout
est cohérent franchement je trouve que
je ne serais pas étonné en plus ils vont
être il n'y a pas de coupe d'europe donc
ils vont être tranquilles ils vont bien
pouvoir se focaliser là dessus
donc s'il réalise un bon début de saison
a déjà contre lyon ils ont un premier
test si ça rigole sur la première
journée presse
ça peut continuer avec un favori pour ce
match justement monaco lyon n'a pas aidé
à des mounaques aux équipes monaco
restait là dessus mais surtout que je
pense que lyon va avoir besoin d'un tout
petit pôle position pour retrouver la
bonne carburation donc monaco sa
différence agressivement il ya des
équipes qui arrivent près des équipes où
ça risque d'être plus longtemps en fait
à se mettre en route
on valide de l'autre partie du tableau
maintenant on va laisser les grandes
équipes et penser un peu à qui pourrait
être relégable alors je tiens à
mentionner que l'an dernier les deux
vincent duchène et édité tous les deux
d'accord avec le camp descendez d'accord
donc là c'était bien donc voilà vous
avez un peu la pression
donc si vous verrez vous voyez des
cendres je veux dijon descendre je pense
que ça va être compliqué pour les
dijonnais ils ont perdu pas mal de
joueurs sai kaba rosiers quan ils n'ont
pas recruté grand chose ils ont un
entraîneur se jobard qui voilà qui a pas
une grosse expérience sur le banc en
ligue 1 donc voilà il flirtait avec avec
cette zone rouge
on l'a vu avec antoine kombouaré la
saison dernière j'ai un peu peur pour
dijon et puis dans les clubs un petit
peu plus huppé que je vois en grand
danger c'est toulouse
je pense que toulouse la belle endormie
là depuis depuis quelques années qui
arrivent pas qui est tout le temps en
train de jouer pour qui lutte pour le
maintien ça fait quand même un moment
qui flirte avec la forte avec le avec la
relégation il propose pas grand chose en
terme de jeu alain casanova est revenu
l'année dernière sur le banc il avait
commencé à mettre en place quelque chose
il a été très vite rattrapé par
l'urgence de prendre des points donc ils
ont commencé à à bétonner
voilà à jouer beaucoup moins ils ont
perdu christopher julien qui était le
taulier en défense ils n'ont pas recruté
grand monde
ils ont toujours max alain gradel qui
est assez étonnant je suis vraiment
étonné de qu' aucun club de ligue 1 un
peu plus huppé qui se positionne sera
max alain gradel moi je leur ai très
bien vu à marseille par exemple
il parlait tout à l'heure de de l'attak
de marseille voilà à toulouse un stade
un peu à un peu vide des supporters un
peu résignés voilà j'ai un peu peur de
l'accident
du côté de toulouse cette saison
toulouse juste il ya bien iran khodro
côté william vainqueur un ancien de l de
marseille
ils ont saïd salhi bombay qui a fait le
forcing en visite en irak depuis dix ans
quand même 8 millions d'euros pour pour
saïd alors on appelle ça un joueur qui a
marqué quatre buts la saison dernière
avec dijon voilà je suis assez je suis
assez sceptique pour l'instant sur sur
le tfc c'est ce qui me fait me dire
qu'ils vont vivre une saison galère je
pense déjà j'ai un peu peur pour brest
je pense que même avec tout le respect
que j'ai pour d'aller au bio je pense
que le départ de furlan est quand même
triste après jeu c'est vrai que c'est un
effectif que je connais pas très bien
donc là comme ça sur le papier je pense
que ça va être une saison compliquée
pour eux et puis si je fais un petit peu
le même choix que guillaume en prenant
un club un peu plus et j'ai beaucoup
d'interrogations sur nice voilà ils ont
pour l'instant ils ont dépensé 0 euros
en fin de de recrutement il sortait avec
effroi que ça c'est gratuit lui il était
libre et répondait donc ils ont ils
prennent personnes y perdent bon ils
n'ont pas perdu grand monde hyper bon
attaquant maxime 1 cm ce qui est ce qui
n'est pas rien bon mais il perd pas mais
je sais pas je rejoins le jouet leur
onze de départ jouait la saison dernière
qu'ils ont fait et les matches de
préparation il est mal catastrophique
exemple et 6-1 contre dynamique
il n'y a pas de je ne sais pas où va ce
à ce club mais j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il aille dans la bonne direction
quand on voit la saison qui avait fait
les niçois il ya deux ans qui était qui
était qui était plutôt prometteuse
derrière rien du tout tendrement alors
peut-être quand les relégables j'ai
peut-être un peu pour savoir que quand
ils vont ils vont avoir chaud savoir si
que le club est en étant dans ce cas ce
que j'allais dire c'est que c'est quand
même ça qu'il aura aussi posé beaucoup
de problèmes s'il ya beaucoup de flou
autour de ce rachat ça traîne un petit
peu en longueur
du coup ils savent pas je pense qu'ils
ont pas encore de enveloppe pour le
mercato donc ça va être ça va être
compliqué pour le fournissement le
rachat est fait maintenant mais par
contre effectivement le rachat a été
fait enfin été validée en plein milieu
mercato c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
préparer un mercato c'est on parlait
tout à l'heure des équipes qui peuvent
pas être prête au jour j de la saison
nice en fera clairement partie n en
pigments typiquement nantes aussi avec
ses tombée il ya quelques il ya quelques
heures l'arrivée de chris bangle feaster
le revenu annoncée c'est très compliqué
en terme de préparation avec un
entraîneur vahid elodie qui claquent la
porte à quelques jours de la reprise
christian gourcuff c'est un choix qui
peut étonner quand même on sait que
c'était passé un petit peu sous les
radars on est un petit peu surpris de
l'entendre ça aujourd'hui c'est un
entraîneur bâtisseur christian gourcuff
on l'a vu à lorient
l'expérience à rennes 2 x n'avait pas
fonctionné
on connaît l'impatience de la présidence
nantaise ce qui laissera le temps de
construire quelque chose il arriva
équipe qui est déjà fait quasiment il a
plus de trois semaines de mercato
beaucoup disent qu'il va pas rester plus
de trois mois oui on peut pas dire pour
l'instant mais oui oui sa part une
mission assez assez difficile a le
mérite de la relever
il était libre depuis son départ du
qatar au début juin la guerre a fait don
qu'il a il relève le défi nantais il va
y avoir du boulot c'est pas facile pour
qui son docu s'il n'y a pas grand monde
qui fait commander presser au portillon
pour aller enfin on se connaît pas tous
les tenants et aboutissants mais bon
le gâteau aux crédits non claude puel
thiago motta selon l'équipe montera donc
après c'est forcément la personnalité de
waldemar kita qui doit poser problème à
certains ils ont peut-être pas envie
d'avoir un président entraîneur entre
guillemets qui est qui qui au milieu du
chemin tout le temps il ya une équipe on
va parler parmi les relégables cms vous
la voyez vous voyez l'équipe restée en
rester en ligue 1 moi je les vois je la
vois bien rester en ligue 1 cette année
parce qu'ils ont ils ont fait une
excellente saison 10 de vraiment
fantastique qu'ils étaient vraiment au
dessus du lot ils ont gardé l'ossature
de l'équipe dans son union bon
entraîneur
même si c'est frédéric antonetti qui
était à la base un autre à la tête de
l'équipe mais il a des problèmes
personnels donc du coup il a laissé la
main aux lions qui je l'écoutais encore
à la radio hier soir d'y aller à la [ __ ]
plutôt de l'ambition dans le jeu il veut
pas il veut pas arriver et fermer
boutique derrière alors il sait qu'il
sera forcément des moments où ils vont
ils vont souffrir face à des grosses
équipes de ligue 1 mais voilà c'était
une bonne équipe de très bonnes équipes
de ligue 2 la saison dernière notamment
en attaque avec pas mal de pas mal de
talent moi je les vois bien je vois bien
se maintenir cette année
est-ce qu'on l'ait peut-être même bref
c'est une équipe qui peut lui que
surprendre pas surprendre deux top 10 on
va parler du décalage de wereldhave
tranquille je suis tranquille est-ce
qu'on peut l'avoir un peu comme une
équipe l'an dernier on se rappelle de
nîmes qui a fait qui a fait une très
bonne saison pour sa remontée
ça apprend que ça est un petit peu plus
compliqué pour nîmes cette année parce
qu'ils ont perdu tous les tous les cas
l'enfant tout cas tous les grands noms
dont on parlait avec tous les joueurs
qui se sont distingués on va dire la
saison savalli
bonga tube ferry aussi qui était qui
était en prêt ouais ça retour de près
donc
donc voilà nîmes d'ailleurs l'entraîneur
a attiré un petit peu la sonnette
d'alarmé
ils disent qu'ils appellent ils ont ils
avaient besoin de recrutement président
doit recruter d'accord nîmes aussi du
coup vous ça vous voyant en bas de
tableau parole et gamme mais en bas de
tableau de saison difficile regardez
maintenant que des de la delà de la
surprise
quelle équipe pour vous peut créer la
surprise alors jusqu'à deux fois plus à
dire que l'an dernier quelqu'un m'a dit
il ils ont sans surprise ce qui avait
plutôt bien réussi qui vous voyez cette
saison cédric d'abord que c'est quoi ta
surpris alors moi c'est une ce serait
une surprise sur son honnête rhume parce
que je peux reprendre je prends
montpellier moi je vois bien montpellier
je trouve que le le le recrutement de
montpellier et cohérent bon ils ont ils
ont perdu le compte ils ont perdu à
lille aguilar pardon mais bon ils ont
pris savagnier ils ont en attaque ils
ont un tandem de l'or laborde qui est
raymond en dise mollet qui sera très
bien c'est une équipe qui est bien
équilibrée qui est stable quand même
globalement qui a des tauliers en
défense qui sont là ça soit qu'on veut
ou les tonnes hilton j'ai 41 42 s'est
fait danser la foule ont fait cueillir à
l'unive maintenant on a eu tort et donc
voilà c'est une équipe qui est qui qui
je pense a largement les moyens de faire
une belle petite saison peut-être pas
rêver top 5 mai
elle est au top 6 top 7 alors je jouais
pas je vois pas comme lille dont ils
vont pas fait ils vont pas finir le
dauphin qu'après ils ont même été
champion exactement quand rencontre face
au psg face aux tâches à leurs débuts de
l'ère ici à paris mais non mais
effectivement on se retourna et puis ce
milieu savagnier ferry qui jouait l'an
dernier en plus ça nous convient bien
marché à la anime donc ya pas de raison
que ça marche ou pas à montpellier
surtout je répète devant il ya mollet
qui est bien un très bon un très bon
jeune donc de deux vrais bons buteurs
sur le bon il ya quelques quelques bons
joueurs de devoir toujours camarades
comment des choses comme ça non c'est
nelson un effectif bien construit ça
peut attraper l'europe ça dépend ça
dépend si un réveil de monaco si un
réveil de marseille là on
et puis on n'a pas encore parlé de lille
mais mais ouais ça peut rattraper
l'europe ça peut attraper une coupe
sicile psg pas trop revanchard sur les
deux couples peuvent faire ce qu'a fait
strasbourg saison dernière ils peuvent
le faire
gilliam toi tu as ça soit à surprises
cette année
moi ce serait saint-etienne alors
comment une surprise ça veut dire se
battre
le podium où la quatrième place
européenne je pense que saint-etienne a
un vrai coup à faire alors ils
raviraient il renoue avec la coupe
d'europe
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être ça qui pourra
éventuellement le relais freiner un
petit peu en championnat qui va falloir
faire faire tourner être un petit peu
sur tous les fronts les ans des
effectifs ils ont un droit là exactement
c'est pour ça que je les mets en
surprises potentielles ils ont un super
effectif dont il ya jean louis gasset
qui est parti qu'ils avaient une grosse
cote d'amour auprès de ses joueurs mais
ghislain printemps et 13 aussi très aimé
aussi des joueurs d'ailleurs les cadres
sainte stéphanois ont dit la plupart ont
dit c'est soit il reste soit on s'en va
donc ils ont eu gain de cause là dessus
c'était déjà une très belle équipe la
saison dernière avec des tauliers comme
debuchy comme m'vila évidemment ruffier
dans les buts
khazri devant perrin évidemment il ya eu
l'explosion de saliba en défense
centrale cette petite pépite alors
qu'ils vont réussir à garder at elle
seulement ils ont réussi un très beau
coup en le vendant à arsenal et en se
faisant prêter jusqu'à la fin de la
saison avec un chèque au passage de 30
millions d'euros donc
qui est vraiment un bon coup pour
saint-etienne et puis ils ont ils se
sont débarrassés enfin débarrassé entre
guillemets c'est à dire ça ils ont
laissé partir
vous comprendrez pourquoi je dis ça ils
ont laissé partir cabella mais pour un
gros chèque ils ont pris 12 millions
d'euros ce qui est une affaire en or
pour un joueur de ce calibre et ils ont
réussi alors ils ont récupéré boudebouz
qui est une valeur sûre d'alors il était
plus en ligue 1 mais ces dernières
saisons mais qu'il a comme quelques
saisons galères des examens
il a toujours ses bourgs lire c'est ça
ça reste un très beau c'est un très bon
joueur de foot
je pense que pour le coup ils ont ils
ont faim ils ont fait un bon coup avec
lui et puis bon gars ont parlé de nîmes
tout à leur attaquant plutôt prometteur
troc aussi alors ça c'est vraiment le je
pense que c'est un des très bons coups
du mercato
seulement ce latéral péruvien il était
dans l'équipe type du pérou de la copa
america était finaliste de la copa
america ils ont payé un minot ce qui est
ridicule sur le marché des transferts
alors il lui restait six mois 36 mois de
contrat il ya plusieurs clubs de ligue 1
qui était sur lui il va à saint-etienne
je pense que ça aussi c'est c'est un
très bon coup pour pour saint-etienne et
aussi à oulu au milieu de terrain qui a
bon joueur avec un bon potentiel à côté
de m'vila je pense que ça fera la faire
pour l'appui khazri qui reste une valeur
sûre de l'allier en attaque
voilà moi sévère avec geoffroy guichard
qui est toujours là pour porter portée
les joueurs moi je les vois bien un top
3 c'est un peu compliqué mais le top 4
top 5 est ce qu'il va me falloir un
réveil des attaquants enfin hors cac
dream et un johnny en berry palais d
attaquer wen et pas que les attaquants
de pointe on sait que c'est compliqué
ces derniers temps oui oui bon c'est
ouais c'est toujours un peu le buteur ça
c'est vrai vous aimez vos des mecs qui
sont capables de marquer bonne avec un b
l'année dernière ils ont hamouma ils ont
un atout jeunes il ya plein de profils
intéressants
de bons attaquants presse est vrai
qu'ils n'ont pas des mecs qui en me
kadri qui vont marquer quinze 15 buts ou
20 buts dans la saison il ya peu de
clubs en ligue 1 qui en ont finalement
gourine ont aussi leur dire
effectivement cadres et qui a fait une
très bonne saison alors je sais plus
combien de buts il est marqué dans le
chat si vous avez l'information et
n'hésitez pas non plus à nous dire quel
est votre surprise quel sera votre
surprise de l'année on en est maintenant
de la déception qui sait j'appelle la
mèche grave donc moi je m'offre bordeaux
franchement je ne vois pas comment
bordeaux je vois toujours pas où va le
projet je vois pas alors désolé
guillaume et pour moi laurent koscielny
il est cuit a eu quelques mois je il a
été comme souvent blessé il a été
je pense qu'il dit voilà il est bien et
comme il l'a dit il revient pour le
cadre de vie aussi il est en pré
retraite voilà ils ont ils ont rien
acheter ont remis ça et un attaquant sud
coréen ou qui jouait au gamba osaka
donc je sais pas peut-être qu'ils ont
regardé un peu trop les vidéos tottenham
ils sont dit qu'ils vont peut-être
trouver le nouveau mini sonne j'ai bien
peur se soit pas à ce repas secondes
ce campus est pas un jeu joué 25 26 ans
même pas de référence ce véritable
internationale avec avec la sélection
sud coréenne
c'est lui qui pour l'instant est censé
être le numéro 9 dans cette équipe donc
rien ghezzal ac moi c'est une hérésie
non franchement je vois pas à bordeaux
en terme d'effectif c'est dans ces
faibles voilà il faut dire clairement
alors est-ce qu'ils vont être capables
de faire quelque chose sur la fin du
mercato je suis pas sûr je n'ai pas
cette impression parce qu'ils ont quand
même très peu dépensé on la demie pour
la d'hier avec qui à sa fusion ils
dépensent ils dépensent 2 millions sur
le corps et 1,5 sur laurent koscielny
mais ils ont hâte ville voilà donc après
ça c'était peut-être bien ça c'est un
très beau coup
arem je peux vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de supporters qui regrettent le départ
de méchas c'est d'autant plus un bon
coup quand kool shen il sera à
l'infirmerie
non j'aime beaucoup que szczesny mais
franchement je là pour moi bordeaux ça
sera une sachant que l'on parle
forcément si on parle de déception on
n'a pas parlé de d'un bien ou danger on
va pas
bordeaux 6 voilà on avait un internaute
il est placé sur le podium moi je suis
désolé je les vois très loin du podium
guillaume stationnaire ben oui ben je
pense que ce sera compliqué autour de
vous et en tout si ils arrivent à faire
10e 11e 12e déjà il était 14e je crois
la saison dernière à ce qu'ils arrivent
à gratter quatre places telles que
bordeaux n'est pas une grande équipe
qu'on a beau annoncer plus et plus non
j'ai un grand club
voilà ça n'était plus déjà depuis
quelques de saison franck m6 ça faisait
déjà quelques quelques années que de
tavernot avec un prix du recul et il va
décider de plus je suis pas donner
l'impression d'une gestion tranquille où
on va finir 9e 10e
ce sera ça sera déjà très bien la plus
d'ambition dans cette équipe pourtant le
président à vie puisqu'il dit qu'il est
capable de renouer avec la ligue des
champions alors cette enveloppe de 80
millions d'euros annoncés quant au
moment du rachat
c'est un peu flou en fait on sait pas si
c'est sur une deux trois saisons là ça a
pas l'air d'être sur eux ils ont dépensé
10 % après ces passes et un rabais
tweeples peut-être qu'ils vont recruter
il ya encore un petit peu de temps mais
effectivement l'effectif actuel est
d'accord avec cédric ça ira pas très
haut je pense c
et puis de tu parles d'une enveloppe de
80 millions faut voir pour savoir qu'ils
ont quand même vendu
comme d
ben 25 25 15 25 millions donc ça veut
dire que pour l'instant ils ont même ils
sont bien remplis les poches passé je
pensais peut-être qu'il a inspirés par
par monaco et blessés qui vont en
décider
pour l'instant ils investissent rien il
y en a aucune rumeur de deux joueurs un
peu un peu glamour un peu sexy enfin
tous non moi je vois je sais pas ou à
bordeaux mais vont pas plus haut que la
saison dernière en trombe a priori très
bien toi qui hante la déception de
l'année on a un peu parlé tout à l'heure
ouais c'est une honte c'est vrai que
c'est pas un club qu'on voit
en haut de tableau en ce moment
malheureusement c'est quand même une
place forte du football français on se
souvient de des canaris de coco suaudeau
et de ronaldinho excès des équipes qui
nous ont fait rêver avec un jeu
développé les ché voilà des équipes
magnifique depuis quelques années voilà
non t'es vraiment dans le dur et puis et
puis c'est vrai que j'ai donné ce nom
avant que de savoir que christian
gourcuff à l'arrivée donc on était
encore plus dans le flou parce qu'on
partait sur sur un début de saison avec
patrick collot comme comme entraîneur un
intérimaire qui avait fait un match je
crois avec lille il ya quelques années
comme comme entraîneur pour enfin comme
entraîneur de l'équipe nationale
première équipe on va dire plus comme
adjoint donc oui ça me paraît ça me
paraît très compliqué pour nantis sont
sur le sur le papier c'est pas c'est
assez ils ont recruté ils ont 10 ans
recruté beaucoup de joueurs mais mais ça
fait pas vraiment rêver les supporters
il ya une vraie fracture
en fait entre les supporters et waldemar
kita on a l'impression que ça et on a
l'impression que quoi qui fera
malheureusement il aura du mal à les
rattraper donc il ya eu des rumeurs de
vente du club
il ya quelques semaines ça a pas abouti
même plus que les rues mais on a eu des
négociations ça n'a pas abouti
donc donc voilà nantes nantes file un
mauvais coton depuis plusieurs saisons
j'ai pas l'impression que
malheureusement christian gourcuff soit
l'homme idoine alors on espère pour les
canaris canaris évidemment mais voilà on
disait tout à l'heure vu son profil
entraîneur bâtisseur il arrive je vais
voir jouer déjà les pompiers de service
même s'ils n'ont pas encore eu de
ils ont pas encore joué de match en
ligue 1 voilà ça me paraît ça me paraît
très très compliquée pour nantes la
saison
voilà maintenant du mercato même fait
une fois de plus ce mercato n'est pas
encore finie qui pour vous restiez à la
mieux se se renforcer qui a fait le
meilleur mercato pole s'est d'abord
alors j'ai eu beaucoup de mal je
regardais un peu j'ai pas vu une équipe
pour moi ya pas une équipe qui qui qui
sort du lot on a parlé évidemment du psg
vont avec leurs moyens et tous et c'est
difficile de comparer forcément le
mercato du psg avec avec avec les autres
équipes
donc moi je vais je vais rester un petit
peu dans la lah dans la poursuite de mon
équipe surprise je dirais que
montpellier a peut-être fait le mercato
le le plus malin je pense que c'est
l'équipe qui s'en sort le mieux
montpellier guillaume mais on en parle
tous alors monaco ils n'ont pas recruté
énormément de joueurs mais voilà ils ont
par petites touches les deux
montpelliérains qu'il fallait aguilar et
le conte le comtat des meilleurs
gardiens de ligue 1 qui a été appelé par
didier deschamps la saison dernière et
puis aguilar qui remplace poste pour
poste sidibé c'est un très bon coup
comme je disais tout à l'heure il avait
déjà préparé en la saison dernière
l'hiver dernier avec un joueur comme
fabregas est quand même une référence
mondiale or c'est le grand pavois gaz
mais ça reste ça reste un manieur de
ballon exceptionnel voilà par petites
touches ils ont ils ont ils ont réussi
leur mercato selon moi avec
effectivement ce ces nigériens honni et
kourou qui avait cartonné l'année
dernière en
en turquie je vois avec galatasaray il
me semble il était prêté par everton qui
va arriver
et après il ya quand même cet inconnu
que dont je parlais tout à l'heure au
tour de autour de falcao
si falcao ou par qui prennent un billet
d'air je pense que ça s'est plutôt c'est
plutôt bien effectivement encore que
j'ai encore un peu de mal à croire que
ben yedder soit vraiment tenté par par
l'as monaco on sache le rôle qu'il a
sévi et on n'est pas loin de l'euro
aussi donc qu'est ce qu'il a vraiment
intérêt à repartir dans un nouveau
challenge je sais pas même s'il
présentait pas un énorme risque en
allant à monaco la concurrence a sévi en
plus il a ouais c'est vrai qu'il a de la
concurrence tant qu il faut être tentés
de partir effectivement on a parlé aussi
de marianne et au diaz ancien joueur de
lyon or femmes albert de monaco c'est
toujours un club qui attire que ce soit
la qualité de vie pas les supporters
voilà une
mais ils sont assez mine de rien les
joueurs sont aussi assez tranquille de
ce côté là ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
une pression monumentale sur les épaules
voilà moi je trouve que monaco pour
l'instant ils ont fait un bon
recrutement mais par contre il faut
qu'ils aillent il faut qu'ils recrutent
en attaque jardim l'a dit une fois d
arriver parce que je suis vraiment trop
juste
en défense il recrutera pas milieu de
terrain non plus et puis il ya eu la
balle dès qu'il revient keïta bal des
mois que je trouvais intéressant il ya
deux ans il a pas réussi à s'imposer il
était très forte
ligue des champions tout de suite on
attendait vraiment qui qu'ils soient
performants tout de suite il a pas il a
pas évidemment il n'a pas donné ce qui
ce qui devait donc là il revient
effectivement de près peut-être que ce
sera la saison de l'explosion pour lui
avec monaco moi je trouve que monaco
fait un bon recrutement moins ce qu il
ya une autre équipe que j'ai cité alors
en plus haute est celle il allait il
faut beau rebond déjà en rayon départ
c'est sûr ils ont perdu pp voilà ça ça
tu es certain tiago mendes leao ils ont
perdu deux maisons très très bien vendu
je suis plus pour combien il est entendu
en tout mais ça doit approcher les sens
et 80 millions ppm routiers doivent
aller ça doit faire 140 millions à la
louche environ donc déjà ces deux très
belle très belle vente
ensuite ils ont pris des joueurs qui
sont assez intéressants moi j'aime
beaucoup le
benjamin andré et qu'ils ont pris de
rennes qui a été souvent blessé mais qu
un très bon joueur qui peut très bien
remplacer tiago mendes voilà après ils
ont tenté
yans ici et l'attaquant c'est ozil m
donc ça c'est va falloir voir il a été
très bon en belgique
ils ont ils avaient déjà eu le nez avec
l'hérault donc moi j'ai une vraie
curiosité par rapport à ça là comme ça
ça a l'air d'être une catastrophe quand
tu quand tu perds pépé ou des choses
comme ça c'est tu dis que c'est vraiment
pas bons mais ils ont encaissé beaucoup
d'argent et ils ont pris des joueurs qui
vont vraiment est à suivre
on connaît la qualité de glisse campos
et leurs recruteurs du monde
alors est ce pas lui ce qu'en pause on
allait discuter avec gérard lopez ya
quelques mois il nous disait toute façon
nous ici là il a deux trois coups
d'avancé à chaque poste il a déjà des
noues longtemps à l'avant 6 mois al
avance sur les sur les joueurs
potentiels a récupéré aux cadres en cas
de départ je suis assez d'accord avec
cédric qu'ils ont fait pour moi il on a
crié un petit peu au nous en voyant tous
ces départs parce qu'à la base il avait
annoncé qu'il y aurait eu un ou deux
bonnes sorties notamment pour nicolas pp
ils ont vendu plus que prévu mais je
pense qu'ils ont réussi à
ils ont réussi à recruter les bons
joueurs on attend de voir quand même
plaisant il encore une marge de
manoeuvre en plus intéressante sur le
plan financier donc on va voir s'ils
peuvent aussi en fin de mercato réussir
encore un ou deux petits coups sûrs des
joueurs voilà qui est qui qui seront
peut-être un peu moins cher un peu
brader peut-être besoin d'un ou deux
joueurs d'expérience enfin leur mercato
est pas forcément terminée il ya bamba
en plus qui est resté ils étaient quatre
on regrette souvent que voulez vous les
voyez à quel à quelle place
cette saison lyon est ce qu est-ce qui
est ce qu ils peuvent ils liés pardon
avec la ligue des champions ils vont ils
vont forcément perdre un petit peu
d'énergie en route
je dirais entre 6,7 ce serait pas mal
6/7 6/7 je pense qu'ils ont les moyens
de le faire bon en ligue des champions
sera plus compliqué s'il arrive à
accrocher la ligue europa déjà 3e place
du groupe il faut voir le tirage au sort
mais ce serait déjà très bien
voilà 6e 7e je pense qu'ils sont
capables de le faire j'ai droit à un
joker c'est par rapport à ce qu'on
disait sur le recrutement par rapport à
leurs niveaux de iasi si bon on les
connaît on les connaît pas encore ses
joueurs donc il faut voir si andré je
touche du bois pour lui ne se blesse pas
arriver à faire une saison pleine
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'inconnues 6,6
décidé joueurs qu'ils ont pris se révèle
très bon c'est pas moi c'est top 5 après
6,6 la mayonnaise ne prend pas si
effectivement c'est les ici ça fait
pschitt
bon voilà c'est ça va être plus
compliqué mais même même pour un top 10
ça va être le projet qui me rend
optimiste c'est christophe galtier qui
met lui meilleur entraîneur de ligue 1
qui sait vraiment qui est vraiment un
très bon entraîneur capable de voilà de
faire monter un groupe très où on l'a vu
à saint-etienne notamment où il n'avait
pas forcément des moyens énormes
donc voilà c'est ce qui me rend
optimiste sur sur l'île alors on va
prendre une très bonne remarque là notre
ami icloud sa rivale à lire c'est sur
montpellier je veux y verra le temps
parce qu'on n'a pas en quoi le fait que
montpellier finit ce top 6 octobre sept
concerts et la surprise de l'année dans
la mesure où ils finissent 6e l'an
dernier il faut s'oublier un peu plus
c'est vrai ce serait vraiment voilà les
quatre quatrièmes à le trio quatrième il
nous dit aussi que lyon ne finira pas
deuxième parce que la ligue des
champions plus le nouveau coach il y
aura des turbulences plus tôt - da cunha
jardine et pas d'europe sans cependant
préciser sur monaco le fait qu'ils aient
pas d'europe sera un facteur important
après lyon a quand même les fictifs le
nouveau coach de nouveau coach est
toujours pareil ces horreurs va vite va
vite savoir si la mayonnaise prend on
pas un avantage c'est que avec juninho
ils ont l'air d'être complémentaires ils
ont l'air d'être solidaire donc il n'y a
pas l'air
claude parle de turbulences et a pas
l'air d'avoir de turbulences entre les
deux alors après sa dérive et du jeu
quelques secondes aujourd'hui à 8 août
sera peut-être pas celle du 8 octobre
qui prennent 3 0 demain déjà on va
commencer à en parler peut y avoir ouais
ouais mais bras jean michel aulas et
comme suffisamment intelligent pour
permettre de turbulence tout de suite il
a dit dans le parisien ce matin qui
laissait du temps il savait qu'il avait
besoin de temps pour construire alors
c'est lyon donc évidemment il faut quand
même jouer les premières places mais
tout le monde est à l'air assez d'accord
pour laisser du temps à ce duo surtout
les supporters
quand on voit ce que genesio a vécu
pendant pendant des années à lyon à voir
les supporters avec soi c'est déjà
énorme avantage pour pour le duo
sylvinho juninho qui a une cote d'amour
incroyable
du côté de new york alors le retour de
juninho a été unanimement saluée avec
son statut de légende
on a notre un internaute alors qu'il n'a
pas de qui n'a pas de pseudo 72000 qui
nous dit que lyon a de grandes ambitions
je trouve monaco avant trop faible et
qui dit on connaît le champion déjà
est-ce que monaco est effectivement un
banc trop faible pour vous donc il
arrive quand même à avoir un effectif
assez complet
comme disait cédric qui joue pas la
coupe d'europe donc fin du mois il faut
qu'ils recrutent en attaque ça c'est sûr
mais jardim là encore là encore dit hier
qu'il n'allait pas recruter dans les
autres secteurs de jeu donc je pense que
son ca veut dire que son camp jardinier
quelque chose à dire il le dit en
général
donc ça veut dire que si la silla il est
satisfait de sa défense et son être son
milieu de terrain il suffit juste de te
dire deux joueurs en attaque et puis ça
devrait faire la malle je crois
sincèrement trop faible surtout qu'ils
ont plein la même saison qui doit être
très très plein de matchs donc non je
pense que de ce qu'il faut de monaco les
rues sinon ils ont commandé le comptant
gardien numéro un
soudas zych qui pourrait se refaire au
chaos avec de la peu de concurrence ça
pourrait lui faire des biens aussi en
numéro sur le papier cette équipe elle
est vraiment belle
le milieu de terrain golovin fabregas
avance avec ce lord et redisent leur
dernier l'équipe était sur le papier
assez belle mais assez construit devant
la rapidité
oui et sa veste et a vraiment pris oui
mais je pense que oui mais là ils
auraient ya des joueurs qui ont un nom
plus bas golovin par exemple qu'on en
plus pas beaucoup vu la saison dernière
parce qu'il avait mangé les blessés si
cette année l'épargné parlée par les
pépins non je pense pas que ben sera
trop faible sauf bien évidemment à à
penser qu'ils y aura une hécatombe de
blessures c'est sûr s'ils n'ont pas de
chance et qui perd trop quatre
titulaires oui peut-être que nous là
comme ça vu mener non je trouve pas si
votre question on part et star du
mercato réussi le meilleur mercato c'est
quoi le pire mercato qui a été fait
jusque là pour vous on les a un peu sera
pour moi je les ai déjà un peu cité
bombe à nice n'y avait rien pris et qui
perd saint maximin on sait pas où ils
vont bordeaux qui ne se renforce pas un
marseille marseille qui pour l'instant
ne fait all in sur benedetto en espérant
qu il soit bon et que ça ça masque le
fait qu'ils aient pris strictement
personne à côté
voilà je pense que ces trois là par
rapport aux moyens qui sont les leurs
normalement on est censé avoir des clubs
qui a tiré en reculant un peu d'ambition
c'est prince et des trois échecs pantois
les nie complètement d'accord avec avec
avec cédric je pense que les supporters
de nice ouest doit être un petit peu
inquiet parce qu on parle elle qui
freinent thuram ce à l'arrivée je crois
qu'il ya fabre qui n'a pas pour les
titulaires qui ne devait pas avoir de
saint-maximin qui est quand même inquiet
un joueur qui a des défauts mais qui
reste quand même je tiendrai très
irrégulier mais chers amis la vrai
talent il s'éclate à le créateur d'apple
on a vu leur apporter une dizaine de
points sur un maximum entre guillemets à
lui tout seul
après patrick vieira a déjà montré qu'il
avait dit qu'il avait du talent pur pour
pour optimiser le niveau des joueurs
pour qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont proposé
du jeu la saison dernière
voilà là il a un vrai challenge devant
lui et puis on espère qu'ils voulaient
me recruter avant la fin du mois d'août
là il faut aussi que leur gardien et
leur défense reste au même niveau que
l'an dernier parce que l'ordre est la
deuxième meilleure défense se croient
les gardiens c'est une série nature
ensemble c'est très très longues heures
d'un moniteur
alors que tintin nous dit que monaco
vient de conclure projet freine adélaïde
on va on passait bien on va vérifier ça
ce sera beaucoup pour moi un bon coup et
alors c'est de ceux déjà un très très
bel espoir
après sur cette saison dans laquelle on
fait régler ça avant d'un accord entré
en jeu ces accords c'est bon je m'occupe
selon l'équipe pouvait retrouver sur le
site de sport24 com en même temps
effectivement on est sur le site de
sports est d'être en même temps 20
millions d'euros 20 millions d'euros
c'est nous c'est essayer c'est une belle
somme roger qui fait encore une belle
plus value c'est un bon recrutement
c'est un bon recrutement pour cette
saison a priori je pense qu'il est
plutôt destiné à être remplaçant donc
mais mais oui ça c'est un vrai un vrai
bon potentiel un jeune qui c'est tout à
fait dans l'optique de ce que fait
monaco depuis des années voilà ça peut
être comme ça ça peut être un du calibre
d'un teen love c'est un peu le horse est
pas tout à fait le même type de joueur
mais c'est un peu le même le même poste
et puis le terran qui confirme à plus 15
avec ses 25 ils ont revendu 40 45
il est très bon très bien vraiment la
même chose avec avec oui alors ils ont
quand même très bien vendu pour un
joueur qui n'a pas confirmé comme
ailleurs comme ils auraient dû
effectivement un monaco ils ont il faut
pas oublier que monaco a plus de 60
joueurs sous contrat oui ce qui est
énorme donc ils sont six lancers dans
une grosse opération de dégraissage
tous les jours on voit des noms partir
de joueur qu'on connaît pas forcément
mais oui très très très bon coup droit
vers le soleil qu'ils ont leurs clubs
satellites comme on dit sacs de bruges
je crois vous qui est qui a qu'ils
envoient des joueurs en prêt pour ce
pour se former une question de tintin
donc on en parlait un peu tout à l'heure
de bresse est ce que pour vous ils ont
réalisé un bon mercato alors peu petit
col peut-être
on n'avait pas beaucoup travaillé sur
place alors on allait fiche un peu
les fiches peu voilée alors je descends
tu parles alors je sais qu'ils ont
récupéré grandsir de monaco qui a jamais
pas vraiment c'est pas le grand bâtiment
et j'avais oublié grandsir parce qu'il
arrive la pac
il n'a pas confirmé effectivement à
monaco j'ai surtout été expulsé il avait
fait graver en retard dont il avait été
très bon avec 3 on s'en souvient donc
c'est peut-être un bon club pour se
relancer effectivement grandsir
charbonnier charge harmonie meilleur
buteur de ligue 2 ça peut ça peut
marcher effectivement ça c'est du c'est
un bon pari je pense pour stade brestois
charbonnier effectivement qui était
meilleur buteur mais qui a joué de la
dja la ligue arabe qui tarde à ce qui
était très très irrégulier quand même je
me souviens c'était assez compliqué ils
ont aussi recruté romain perreault à
nice alors s'il joue en ligue 2 l'an
dernier il a fait une très bonne saison
en ligue 2 et nice l'a vendu pour 2
millions mais c'est que à côté de ça via
bâle voilà ludovic balle de rennes
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de grands
noms de ces souvent grèce a besoin d'eux
c'est tout c'est souvent qu'avec les
clubs qui montent celle ci qui se dit se
basent d'abord sur l'ossature de
l'équipe qui a obtenu la montée après
c'est lui c'est dû dire c'est par
petites touches dans cette dans cette
liste de recrues et grandsir ça peut
être ça peut être un bon coup est une
bonne façon de se relancer pour lui
voilà tintin et n'hésite pas à le dire
parce que tu penses toi de ce mercato il
dit nous et de nous dire un peu à ton
avis quel autre club a pu réaliser un
bon mercato on va passer un peu aux
joueurs à suivre
il nous dit que la grossir c'est pas mal
priori oui pardon pardon non tout va
bien on va aborder des joueurs à suivre
pour cette saison dont vous en avez
peut-être plusieurs chacun il ya
beaucoup de toi ce serait qu'ils se le
joueur à suivre cette saison
bah pour moi c'est dario bien des sucres
des joueurs aussi le scénario benedetto
toutes les raisons dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure
marseille une attente énorme après les
flops mitroglou
même balotelli c'est jeudi restera pas
il laissera pas une grande trace il est
resté que six mois avec un côté un peu
mercenaires voilà benedetto sait le
l'attaquant que tous les marseillais
attendaient alors il n'y a pas une carte
de visite énorme on va là voyons là
quasiment jamais vu jouer très peu
j'avoue que c'est un joueur qui reste
encore un mystère
je me fie sur les stades fils lorsque je
vois sur sur twitter avec certains
spécialistes du foot sud américain mais
j'ai envie d'y croire parce que voilà il
a il a un côté argentin donc qui va qui
colle bien avec avec la mentalité
marseillaise des joueurs qui mouillent
le maillot qu'ils lâchent rien faut
espérer que son genou le laisse
tranquille et que voilà que son physique
est globalement le laisse tranquille
dans le système de vilas boas 104 3 3 je
pense que c'est un bon point d'ancrage
voilà bon numéro 9
voilà donc dario benedetto forcément il
y aurait la lumière sur lui dont je
pense que c'est le joueur un des joueurs
qui va être suivi le deuxième que je lis
moi c'est pablo sarabia du psg voir qui
est un joueur de complément à priori si
on prend le onze de départ du psg mais
qui m'a fait une grosse impression mois
pendant la préparation parisienne
notamment au trophée des champions je
n'avais jamais vu jouer au stade j'ai
trouvé que c'est un joueur vraiment
vraiment précieux je sois dans le la
qualité de passe
les replis les courses offensives les
replis défensifs sacré joueur pour moi
pablo sarabia fera mal au sixi faire de
trois énormes saison assez exactement
mais il s'est pendu par différents une
star online star intérieur jour de liga
les mélodies les gars c'est un très très
bon courir je pense que là il a franchi
un palier qui est très intéressant pour
lui je pense que ça peut être vraiment
le facteur x du psg en sorties dont est
peut-être mieux la parole il joue il
s'appelle thomas stores elle l'a fait
jouer sur le côté droit mais je pense
qu'il est capable d'évoluer un petit peu
partout et très bonne pioche
excellent sur coups de pied arrêtés très
dangereux donc voilà pablo sarabia pour
moi c'est le
le deuxième joueur à suivre cette saison
cédric tu es joueur tu étais voie à
suivre
pablo est intéressant de le voir mais je
ne mettrai pas tout en haut
non moi j'attends beaucoup de gelson
martins voilà ça s'est il m'a vraiment
impressionné la saison dernière quand il
arrivait alors il a connu un début
tambours battants tonitruant c'était
impressionnant et tout et après il est
un peu retombée maintenant ils arrivent
et il prend pas la saison en cours est
née dans un effectif qui maintenant
qu'il va venir marcher comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure
donc je pense que gelson martin sera
vraiment un joueur à suivre
après si je dois en mettre d'autres
alors j'attends avec impatience de voir
icônes et bamba sans pépé maintenant
d'avoir un petit peu un pps que celui
qui a attiré la lumière et qui leur
permettait sans doute aussi de briller
maintenant il n'est pas là on va
vraiment voir ce que bamba et icaunais
ont dans le ventre
j'ai presque envie de dire donc cesser
c'est pour moi c'est des joueurs à
suivre wall il ya ya's ici aussi un jeu
bien sûr que la turquie ce qui semble
être entre le plus gros transfert de
l'histoire de lille c'est un joueur de
22 ans il était à trabzonspor il a fait
toute sa carrière à trabzonspor et son
départ a été vécue comme un cataclysme à
trabzonspor on a vu des gamins en pleurs
etc
et apparemment c'est un très très bon
joueur bâillon l'a pas on l'a pas vu
beaucoup joué mais grosse qualité de
passes une bonne orientation du jeu il y
assez rapide
voilà encore je pense que luis campo ci
s'est pas trompé il le voulait depuis
assez longtemps il me suivait depuis
plusieurs mois donc voilà je pense que
ce joueur là aussi moi je m intéresse
effectivement bamba koné il connaît je
suis je suis impatient de voir ce qu'ils
vont donner sens à notre ami nicolas pp
y avoir aussi leur joueur vous en parler
parce que tout appareil marseille on n'a
pas du tout parlé c'est un peu je trouve
ça un peu bizarre quand une femme du
coup maintenant on en parle plus et
ovins fois en trouver
est ce que quelqu'un te rappelles de dia
deux ans il fait une saison si la chine
sont magnifiques
ce jour là sa dernière est assez
irrégulier est ce qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre de lui cette saison
c'est un peu la limite de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure avec mandanda et
paillettes et les cadres marseillais
peut être boosté par l'arrivée de
villas-boas je pense qu'un torrent et
voit revenir aussi à son meilleur niveau
il a fait la coupe du monde certes il a
il a très peu joué mais c'est toujours
difficile de se remettre d'une victoire
enfin d'une coupe du monde est encore
plus d'une victoire avec la pression
avec les sollicitations et c'est donc
c'est toujours que les années post coupe
du monde sont sont difficiles on l'a vu
pour d'autres joueurs et pas des
moindres pensées pour adil rami ou par
exemple ça je dis rien vu ne réalisera
pas une très grande saison du côté de
marseille / constate le centre aussi la
vente ce dont nous parlons est bon c'est
qu'on a on s'attendait à ce qu'ils
partent finalement florian thauvin il
est toujours à marseille
et voilà donc dans ce 4-3-3 de vilas
boas ce moi je le vois vraiment faire
une grosse saison cette année
un dernier une dernière question pour
vous pour avant de clore ce live alors
question un peu facile mais qui sera le
meilleur buteur cette année pas facile
quoique on sait jamais on sait jamais ce
qu'il peut se passer beaucoup de choses
la saison mais on a serré on est assez
unanimes pour dire que c'est évidemment
pour ça qu'il y en ai ma paix maintenant
ça pourrait être un autre joueur
tewanee s'appuie pas déjà il a priori il
devrait être parisien ça pour être né
mars il reste givisiez motivés donc
parce qu'il faut pas oublier comme km à
peine la saison dernière fait une saison
exceptionnelle il me marque combien mes
trente trois 33 34 et mais cavani
n'était pas là cavani risque de revenir
et de tirer les pénalties par exemple je
sais plus combien le bape est un habile
il n'a pas mis une dizaine mais d'un ami
quand même quelques-uns les buts iront
peut-être du côté de cavani il sera
peut-être tour elle veut peut-être joué
en 4-3-3 et tout donc il sera peut-être
un peu moins en pointe que que cette
saison mais franchement je vois pas
comment ça pourrait échapper à une map
et ou cavani ou neymar voilà s'il se
remet à l'endroit
ouais bon point que certains parlent
déjà du record de libra imowicz qui
étaient 38 but pour le psg sur une
saison clairement qu'il ya des maps et
il a tous les tous les atouts pour
atteindre ce total voir le battre moi je
le vois flirte avec la barre des 40 bus
saison cette saison qu'ils adoptent même
sortir les penaltys même privé s'ils ne
tirent pas si les tirs ou et si les tirs
pas ce sera peut-être un peu plus
compliqué mais je vous imagine tous sur
une très grosse saison est-ce qu'il peut
récupérer cette place de pointe qui
convoitent
en face au cabba ni peut pas jouer
ailleurs c'est ça et il l'a dit à
shenzhen lors de la conférence de presse
il ya dix mois il a dit qu'il a été
surpris d'entendre qu'il voulait qu'ils
voulaient par la presse qui voulait
jouer en pointe il a dit moi je veux
jouer avec les meilleurs et cavani fait
partie des meilleurs joueurs
je veux jouer seul si si mais marc s'en
va après faut voir comment ils le
remplacent je sais pas maintenant il
peut y avoir une un changement tactique
c'est à dire qu'il peut passer en 4-4-2
par exemple il peut mettre cavani et mba
paix en pointe par contre s'il reste
dans ce 4 3 3 si cavani n'est pas blessé
si vous mettez amap et cavani vous
mettez sur moi parce que vous avez
permettre cavani sur un côté ou ailleurs
donc donc a priori il n'y a pas d'autres
d'autres alternatives à la tintin qui
nous parle du mercato stéphanois oui on
en parlait tout à l'heure un coût 10
boudebouz à oulu bouanga on l'a vu tout
à l'heure très très très solide très bon
mercato ils ont ils ont vite bouclé leur
mercato en plus c'est vrai que jamais en
ces veilles mois pour moi c'est là la
surprise potentielle de saison la
surprise potentielle eh bien écoutez
merci beaucoup
cédric merci d'avoir été là pour nous
parler de cette la reprise à lien on
vous rappelle que demain il ya monaco
lyon en ouverture à 20h45 à suivre en
direct sur sport24 bien évidemment
n'hésitez pas à suivre également le
mercato en direct qui se passe en ce
moment
ces profils sociaux etc l'angleterre à
sa finale à 18 heures ça devrait tomber
de leur pas mal de panique bail
twilight d'ici 18h si deux heures
beaucoup vont de l'avant vont récupérer
des vous récupérez des attaques en
transit qui dit je ne sais pas si vous
avez reçu mes questions oui je crois
qu'on les a reçus il ya même répandu sur
les noirs et les préparateurs physiques
j'ai l'impression oui oui c'est bon on a
eu on a eu toutes tes questions alors je
voulais voir plus bon voilà bah écoutez
en tout cas merci beaucoup à tous les
deux d'avoir été là merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce direct et on vous dit à bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives sur le football
ou sur d'autres sujets
au revoir au revoir bientôt